well i love his extreme close-ups where
he's like on his eyeball and waking up
into like a little nosebleed and the
movie is amazing
when you begin writing a screenplay i
understand you start with a number
oh yeah
um
well generally say you've already have
the idea and that at this point for me i
believe in the incubation period some
call procrastination which
procrastination does exist but i do
believe your mind your psyche if you're
focusing on one specific tale
there's a period of time that you're
writing a lot of notes down and then
eventually i'll do a paradigm which for
me is writing a line across the top of a
piece of paper and then i always choose
a random number
and the number
for clowning was 34
and i put 34 notches at the top of the
piece of paper and for me this paradigm
is the only blank sheet of paper i'll
ever face
and i'll force myself to put a scene
a little one sentence describing that
scene telling myself the whole story on
that piece of paper
and then from there
i will
once that paper's filled i'll translate
it over to note cards
and as i'm translating every one of
those 34 will become 38 to 40 note cards
on the wall and then obviously when you
write it'll become to 100 scenes
eventually once you're
really breaking it down but for me by
the time i get to writing pages i'll
have already told myself the story in
its entirety
three different times
and so it really frees me up to at that
point just have fun with it and also
improvise
i like the idea of writing and knowing
so much about where i'm going that i can
just forget all of it and just be there
and sometimes the story will take some
lefts or rights but i know where i want
to try to get to in it
and for me personally this all developed
out of the need to finish
the screenplay
and so for me it's as long as i have the
paradigm filled out and the note cards
on the wall then i know that the script
will be written
is that a fear of yours i know you
you're very much about finishing it but
does that plague you
you know the only time i'm ever
feeling a kind of fearful notion as when
i'm doing the paradigm
because i think there's still the
question mark of will this
idea fulfill itself
you know will it fully come to fruition
and so it probably saves months and
months of heartache where you have an
idea and if you just sit down and start
writing and maybe you get 20 pages into
it
and then you get sidetracked and you
don't know where you're going well you
can come back to that screenplay for
months for me maybe three days to a week
if i haven't fleshed out that paradigm
fully i'll generally put it into a very
specific drawer with other ideas where
they'll percolate longer
and so for me it's once the note cards
are on the wall i know that's the next
script that i'll write
and then it also helped me like this
process has now breached
me into being a professional writer and
what that means to me
isn't necessarily making tons of money
or being able to sell scripts quite at
this particular moment but being able to
execute a screenplay in a timely manner
and i think you really have to
compartmentalize your process
to be able to fulfill that need so if a
studio was like you have 30 days
some writers really maybe couldn't sit
down and say they could do it in 30 days
where that process kind of lets me know
like okay it's here and i can push this
faster
so let me see if i understand that
correctly so 34 is almost like plot
points
yes okay yeah so you know i'll also
decide early on if it's going to be 3x
or 2x or 4x
and that's based on
the character the genre what's happening
in it
um
but the number is just a random i mean
i'll even do stuff as far as googling
that number and reading behind it it's
never an odd number i'm an even number
guy so i never do odd numbers
every script ends in an even page
and it ends in an even number of scenes
or i delete a scene
are there numbers that you just think
are bad luck no okay no no no no i think
that numbers are telling us a lot
and
i think if you're open to it you can
it
they're guiding us in particular ways
now this is going into another notion of
life
but screenwriting is all about numbers
right and and getting into a scene as
late as possible out as early as
possible what's the point of the scene
how many pages does that seem
you know i don't know i feel like a lot
of numbers i mean it all is broken down
so much as numbers right like even when
you look at how many lines can fit on
one specific page
so you're always kind of locked into
that realm early on i heard david lynch
say that he would use note cards and if
he got the 56 note cards then he would
know that he had enough to write a
screenplay
and so then
reading lots of screenwriting books over
the early decade of doing it
i ended up grabbing little tiny snippets
from different people's processes
and so yeah so that's what i end up
doing which is interesting though
because i hand write everything so at
some point i end up having a lump of
note cards in my pocket because i'm too
afraid to leave them at home
because there's just too much
information there
oh so you take them with you
depends on the story depends on the
story like the one that's on my wall
right now i'm not i'm much more
confident in what it is
it fell out so fast so simple
but if it's a very complex thing i might
get more nervous and
you know
i'm kind of a nervous person though i go
back to the oven multiple times and
check to make sure the thing's off a
billion times i'll be out the door like
one more second i'll run back inside
check everything again
unplug every charger yeah
or do you have any note cards on you
right now sir do you have note cards on
you no i don't have no cards on me but i
about my next one's on the wall so i
always take pictures of it
so i can zoom in in case something
happens too
and so is that because you're afraid of
that you won't remember it or something
will happen to it i'm afraid the
building's gonna burn down and it's over
and i was gonna have to figure it all
out over again okay
but then you don't put it um on an app
or in the cloud never okay no no no no
no no no
only only because i like to physically
write i do a lot of typing
and then editing when i i don't want to
necessarily edit the future films but
all my past work i've edited and did all
the sound design and mixing and all this
different things generally for most of
them
so i like to be as physical and not
looking at a screen as often as possible
so even
i hand wrote 156 page draft a long time
ago when i was first learning how to
write screenplays i had this notion of
like what if i hand wrote an entire
script
and so i had all these note cards up and
i would choose a random scene and write
it and then at the end when i had it all
written i would put it all back in order
and then i typed the whole thing
i would never do that again but i do
think every story is asking a different
for a different process
like there's a script i've been writing
that doesn't want any pre-production and
it just is there and exploring and
writing that but generally i like the
prepping part of it
does it have anything to do with
numerology
i've read a lot about numerology i
wouldn't say that this necessarily has
to do with that as much as maybe a
little ocd uh but but also
there's a part where i feel like so i've
written maybe 20 30 plus screenplays
and
i feel like every time i sit down to
write there's always a notion of will i
get through this one
you know like i don't know there's
always this kind of notion of like
sitting down and saying you know am i
going to make it
to the end of this thing
and so i love the pre-writing because it
kind of already answers that question
for me especially if it's really alive
and like i'm telling myself the story
and i'm so entertained i lose a couple
hours while just telling myself it
but
did you see pie
oh yeah wait wait darren aronofsky's pie
yeah yeah
definitely interesting yeah i'm just
thinking of just just some brief
scenes just i know it's not the same but
well i love his extreme close-ups where
he's like on his eyeball and waking up
into like a little nosebleed and the
movie is amazing yeah darren arnofsky's
the best he sure is yeah